so you've gotten familiar with the basar
syntax and you're starting to realize it
takes a lot of effort to manipulate and
work with data frames
even basic things like filtering rows
and selecting columns may start out
simple
but the more you want to do the more
variables you have to make and the more
unreadable your code becomes
enter dplyr an art package for data
wrangling that allows you to easily
chain together operations speeding up
your workflow
and it makes your code much more
readable in this video i'll cover the
essentials of dplyr and go over some
common data manipulation scenarios
you'll likely face
the first step is going to be to install
the dplyr package once with
install.packagesd
plier and then load it into your project
with library dplyr
the data frame we're going to be working
with is from kaggle and it contains the
billboard hot 100 songs of the week for
each week dating back to 1958
i trimmed the data to only include the
last 10 years but i'll leave a link in
the description if you want to play with
the data set
looking at the data set there's a column
for the date that week the song title
and its rank for that week along with
some more metrics about the song's rank
history
and how many weeks it's been on the
billboard hot 100 so let's start
learning some deep player
the first concept we're going to cover
is something you'll see being used in
deployer a lot the percent greater than
percent
is used for piping which is when
everything that comes before the pipe is
evaluated
and then passed in as the first argument
into the function that comes right after
the pipe
so if we want to grab the top 10 rows of
our data frame in base r we might do
something like
head billboard 100 and then 10. but with
piping it would be billboard 100
piped into head 10 and that gives us the
same thing
it obviously doesn't make much sense to
pipe in this case but it does end up
making our life easier when we start
chaining functions together
another quick thing to note is that when
you want to pass what comes before the
pipe
into your function as something other
than the first argument you can
explicitly specify that with a period
and piping doesn't only apply to data
frames so we could write the same
expression
as 10 piped into head
of billboard 100 and then comma period
so the 10 would go in that spot and we
can run that
now let's start working with our data
frame there are a few functions in
dbplier i want to go over
and we can group them into a few
different categories there are the
column operations
select and mutate the row operations
filter distinct arrange
and then the group operations group by
summarize and count
the first the player function we're
going to look at is select which is
pretty self-explanatory it selects the
columns of your data frame that you
specify and then drops the rest
so for this example we want to select
the date the rank
the song the artist and the week's on
board columns and we can do this by
passing in our column names as arguments
into
select so after billboard 100 we will
call the select function
with our pipe and we'll select the date
the rank the song
the artist and weeks on board because
it's using these special characters
these hyphens we actually have to put it
in either quotes or back ticks so we'll
write weeks on board
and we can run this and now we just have
those five columns to make it a little
easier
we can actually use the colon between
two column names and it'll grab both
specified columns and then the ones in
between so we'll copy this code
and paste it right under and instead of
date rank song and artist we can just do
date colon artist and this is great if
you have a lot of columns
and i also want to rename this week's on
board column to
weeks popular and i can do that in the
same select function just by writing
weeks popular
and setting it equal to weeks on board
and if i run that i get the same data
frame as before but now
this column is renamed another way of
selecting would be by explicitly writing
the names of the columns we don't want
to select
and then adding a minus in front of it
so in this case if we look at our
original data frame
we're getting all the columns except for
last week in peak rank so going back to
our code
for select we can put in minus
last week minus peak rank and that'll
give us the same thing
except we want to use that other
function to rename the week's on board
column
also one quick thing to note is that
each time i'm running this code i'm not
actually rewriting or overwriting
the billboard 100 data frame i'm just
printing out what the result is
if you wanted to save it you'd actually
have to reassign that variable
but as a general rule i'd actually
recommend not using the same variable
name because you might run into a
situation where
you can run your code once and it works
fine but if you run it again you'll get
an error
because we renamed this column weeks on
board to weeks popular
and when we run it the second time that
weeks on board column no longer exists
so i'm actually going to go back to the
top and reset my data frame by reading
in the original csv
and i'll get rid of this but going back
to our select function there are
actually a few more ways of selecting
columns because you can use helper
functions i'm not going to cover them in
this video but i will leave a link to
this cheat sheet down in the description
and it includes more info about the
select function but also all the other
dplyr functions
so next we're going to move on to mutate
if you want to add new columns to our
data frame
we can use the mute command similar to
select it can take any number of
arguments
and it allows you to specify what you
want the new name of the column to be
so if we go back to our billboard 100
data frame we see that
there are a lot of rows where there's a
featuring artist and i think it'd be
interesting to have a new column that
tells us whether or not the song was a
collaboration or in other words whether
or not
the word featuring appears in the artist
column so we're going to
pipe again and call the mutate function
and we'll create a new column called
is collab which is just whether or not
the song was a collaboration
and we're going to use the grp function
here which is built into base r
and it takes in a pattern to search for
and then the text to search within
and it'll return either true or false
for each of these rows
so we're searching for the word
featuring and we're searching in the
artist column
and if we run that we get this column at
the end called iscolab
and a quick little trick if we want to
have the artist and is collab columns to
be the first two columns in our data
frame
we can actually create another select
and then
select the artist column is collab
column and then
everything which will just grab the rest
of the columns and now you can see that
it's reordered
and let's just go through a couple pages
just to make sure that his collab looks
right
so it looks good there yep these look
good to me so those are the two main
column functions now we're gonna go on
to the row functions
and we're gonna start with filter so
filter can extract rows that meet one or
more criteria
so if we wanted to select all the songs
where the
number of weeks popular is greater than
20 we can go down here
we'll paste this code in just to get our
data frame and we're going to filter for
weeks popular is greater than or equal
to 20
and run that and now we only get songs
in our data frame
where it meets that condition and as i
mentioned we can pass multiple arguments
into filter
if we want multiple conditions so we
want the songs where
weeks popular is greater than or equal
to 20 and also the artist
is equal to drake and now we get only
his popular songs
if we want to use the or conditions so
we want where the songs
were popular for more than 20 weeks and
the artist is either drake
or taylor swift we could use the
vertical bar
and say that the artist is equal to
drake or artist is equal to
taylor swift and now we get both of
their songs but it still meets that
first condition that week's popular is
greater than or equal to 20.
now another quick note is that these are
only going to grab the songs where the
artist name is exactly equal to taylor
swift or drake but not the ones where
there might be a featuring artist
just because the strings won't be equal
so now let's say we want
only the song titles of these drake
songs if we were to filter him
and select the song row we'd actually
have a lot of duplicates as you can see
here
because a lot of these songs were on the
hot 100 for multiple weeks
so that's where the distinct function
comes in and you can pass whichever
columns you want and it'll give you
distinct rows
so we'll paste the code that we wrote
before and we just want the drake songs
we'll add another function onto the end
of this called
distinct song and i want all the drake
songs so i'm going to get rid of this
other filter
and we can run that and now we get 95 of
his songs but it's still in a data frame
if we wanted this in a vector format we
can use that period that i mentioned
earlier for piping
and essentially we can use it as a
placeholder for the data frame
so now it's signifying that this is the
data frame and then we can grab that
column
called song so if we print this out
it'll give us a character vector with
the song names now on to the grouping
operations
these are a little trickier to work with
but they become really powerful for
doing data analysis
if we wanted to get all the drag songs
and order them by
the week's popular column it'd be a
little difficult because the week's
popular column can be different for the
same song
as you see here this is because
billboard releases its data each week so
if a song is on their hot 100 again
a sweet popular column will be higher
this week than all the previous weeks
now one solution would be to group the
songs by song name and then determine
the max number of weeks popular for each
of those songs
so our end goal is to essentially get a
data frame of distinct song names along
with the number of total weeks they
showed up in the hot 100
so we'll first start by calling the
group by function and we want to group
by the song name
now this group by function if we run the
code it actually won't do anything to
begin with it's implicitly grouping our
data but you need to call
one of the group functions on it
afterwards so we're going to call the
summarize function
which essentially summarizes data into a
single row of values for each of the
groups
and we need to pass in a summary
function so we're trying to find out the
highest number that weeks popular is
for each of these song titles so we're
going to use the max function
so we'll call max week's popular and
just like before with
select and mutate we can rename this
column so we'll call it
total week's popular and set it equal to
this max week's popular
and we can run that and now we get each
of the song names as you can see they're
95 songs just like how there were 95
distinct songs before
and we get the max number that they were
weeks popular now there are other
summary functions too
like mean min and again these are on
that cheat sheet but i'll put a link to
that in the description it looks like
these songs are in alphabetical order
but let's say we want to sort them by
this total week's popular column
so we're going to use the arrange
function and i've grabbed the same code
from before
except now i'm just going to pipe at the
end arrange and this will take in one or
more columns
so we can pass in total weeks popular
by default it'll do this in ascending
order but we want this in descending
order
so we can just wrap this in d-e-s-c for
descending
and we also want it to default to being
in alphabetical order
if the total week's popular numbers are
the same so we can pass in a second
column into a range for the song title
and now we run this and we can see that
where the song is thai
it's still in alphabetical order but now
grabbing the top 10 or top 15 would be
really easy we could just call head 10
right after and it would just give us
the top 10 rows
of the songs that were the most popular
so the last function we're going to go
over
which is similar to group by is count
which will count the number of rows for
each unique value
in the column or columns that you
specify so if we wanted to find the
total number of times
that each artist shows up in our data
frame we can simply write
count artist which will create a default
column
called n with each of the artist names
and you can see here the data is not
very clean because
obviously two chains is being listed
here multiple times but we're going to
ignore that for now
but if we want to get this into
descending order
by n we can just arrange descending n
and now we can see the artist that
showed up in our data set the most
number of times
so even though there are a lot more d
plier functions these are the ones
you'll likely find yourself using the
most
in the next video i'm going to cover a
few more scenarios where dplyr can
really come in handy
including cleaning up a data set piping
your data directly into a graph and
merging data sets together to gain
further insights
if you found this video helpful i'd
definitely appreciate if you liked the
video and subscribe to the channel
thanks for watching and i'll catch you
in the next one